hello and welcome everyone to another
pardon meeting 2010 online live
on bs today is
wednesday 3rd november
as you know there is no
college meeting this week and by the way
allow me to report  that several
of my spokesperson colleagues are on
leave and it is well deserved I
therefore count on your understanding
if the replacement is not able
to answer your questions immediately on the podium
of course we will
do our best to get back to you with
the information requested we have
no further announcements to make to you
today and so we can go
straight to your questions and
cherry  just to
ask you does the commission have
enough leeway in this is what
you call negotiations or
technical consultations finally I do
n't know what the word is  xact that you
use to describe
these talks which have been taking place since
Monday morning if I understood correctly what
you said
is what the commission considers that the
sufficiency match of leeway
in this negotiation or is what the
requests for  one side and the other of the
channel are
greater the room for maneuver
that you have is what the chief commissioner is
still in dubai I
don't know anymore I think they were yesterday the day
before yesterday  will he take over this
file himself or will these
consultations remain at a technical level
thank
you I love you and I am happy to repeat
in French we are in a position
where
discussions are positive we have a good
dynamic and the discussions continue
still today it is at the level of the
resource signs of the civil servants at
the moment but obviously there is a
super vision a support of the
political level also they are committed
obviously
thank you I will close the subject because
true  ment we are not going to add anything
you must understand well we are
not going to comment on the
discussions which are in progress so at
the moment so I am willing that we
continue to ask questions but you will
understand that the success  of the
discussions
depends on the ability of the negotiators
to talk to each other and the comments that we
would make here in the press
room would not contribute anything to these negotiations
so we will
leave it there henri iv have
time
to say they need and
dj
radio france concerning this  campaign
of the council of europe on passers-by
fishing excuse me we would do things
by thinking you are right that we would
indeed like to close the subject but
nevertheless out of courtesy I would like to
see if there are other questions on this
point that  is not the case so I do
n't have my word on this campaign
of the council of europe which is co-financed
by the european commission on
online hate speech which is
controversial in fra  nce is it possible to
know what kind of financial support has been given
in what type of
European programs what type of
European program it is do you
approve of this campaign which therefore puts
women with diabetes
who are  made a big controversy
thank you I give the floor to christiane
and hello and thank you for this question
with regard to the campaign which you
mention the project
weekend for human rights pitch of the
council of europe is financed within the
framework of the  call for proposals racism
launched in 2019 as part of the
equality and citizenship rights program
the project generally aims to fight
against cuts in hate speech
online and offline against, for
example, the
Jewish and Muslim communities
by involving young people and
civil society organizations the commission does not participate in
the evolution of the
individual deliverables
of small projects that benefit from
eu grants  and the eu and the
commission has not validated
the deliverables in question go
council of europe is taking a
leading role for the implementation and
a practically of the company
thank you are there any other questions  on this
subject
stone it is on this subject that
you are what you have a figure on the
financing
generally the project le grand grint
which was signed on December 9,
covers
340 million do not have 1000 euros
tracing
340 thousand euros but  I specify it's
not just for these it's for the
campaign as a whole not for the
tweets that were sent there angelic
but wait wait you have to I
understand the you have to wait
for our technicians you see the
plug into the microphone and it's good when
it suits them just a little flop
we understood what you told us
the commission did not validate the
visual elements yes absolutely not
validated it's understood thank you
very much  are there any other questions
So on this subject
I see luca name in the book
yes on these subjects there too our
colleagues who have not mastered
Molière are following us michael
a
[Music]
jeanneau
in
chili in the
local mode will
arrive rested on foot a commission
in  vue au freedom is extremely
clip hold it built
in zurich gives way
women should be good to what he was
wrong way they want to take two of the
country in which
is defined in member states of
supervision and white lies so
we are in which i believe
we  leave
behind
games and fitch
[Music]
for
all the if they funded
under this program we could have
the grant agreement you're talking about right
now
I don't know we have to
we have to see  i don't know if this agreement
is available or not we will check
one will find towards 3
wii
and nicolas gros verheyde but
i will start with you i think this is all
about more on the borders
i saw that the hungarian leader viktor
orban was
asking for funding
i wanted to know
to defend the schengen border
against migrants in its meaning
i wanted to know in the past it
seems to me that you have financed
the building of
different barrier or
barbed wire type measures at the borders it seems to me in the countries
baltes can you
confirm that for me it's
not that it's for christian it's
an internal affairs issue so
it's more for and albert adalbert
hello nicolas
to my knowledge the commission has
never financed a barbed wire
fence wall  at the external borders
and moreover we have a
very clear position on this subject the president
fondane answered a question
on this on October 22
and there she repeated that that there will be
no European funding for
barbed wire or  walls at the external borders
here I think we can't be
clearer than saint nicholas but evasive its
price included the position of the
president may  s me I was talking about
financing under the
internal security fund for in france at the
border it was perhaps not called
barrier as such but I
remember having visited during the
presidency I think layton us and the
ce  which had been set up at one
time was less confrontational and they
had us well it was one of the
examples of the setting up financed by
the European Union at the time and that's not the case
three four years ago
very well nicolas ly
obviously we can look
with not exactly what projects
were financed with what funds
in general obviously the
internal security fund that you mentioned
he his successor whose current financial framework
very substantially finances solutions
management of external borders which
may not include walls
barbed wire but
other other measures
IT systems infrastructure
technology  gic and other other
solutions that are being deployed as
well as human resources so
within the framework of this kind of project
there may be situations where national funds
finance
basic infrastructure or barbed wire of
and  walls and then the funds
reminded to finance others other
aspects of this solution so if you
want we can to look at this
together if you have a specific project
under which you would like more details
but the position of the commission
in general on this question is
such that we have just recalled
thank you are there any other questions on this
subject quentin
yes hello eric can you hear me
yes ouistes hear go ahead yes I can
hear you reserved sybille yes c  it's to
do a bit of a solo for nicolas I
'm also interested
in having a bit of a chance to discuss it
because in my memories the
programs seen there have been European funding
for the smad in the smart
borders and  n bulgaria and others so it is
even possible to have a little the
elements that there is perhaps a reaction
to the letter of victor guyed what
gharbi is what
the request is relayed da even if it
is at the moment  if I understood correctly
with glasgow is she going to speak
with their base about these questions where and
all that
if we have you second on your second
question or rather on your question
since on the first point we
understood his interest and adalbert
will come back to you too we can
confirm that we have received the
letter and we will obviously respond to it
when the time comes and no he has not had a
conversation
on this subject to my knowledge
quentin favorable
is what  'it can be expected that the
question of
financing the protection of the
external borders will be discussed before the end
of the year if memories are good
should still make announcements
on immigration is what we can
s'  wait until the
end question  ancement are addressed in the texts
and proposals the commission
so
thank you thank you when it is obviously
difficult for me to speculate on
what could be addressed in
different frameworks in the future but I will
nevertheless allow myself to clarify one
thing
the question of whether  European funds
finance the management of the
external borders there is no
doubt we have specific funds
which are dedicated to this we
deploy border
management solutions at the borders which are
modern which are sophisticated which are
which are effective which are also in
line with European values
European law and which are then linked
to migration management procedures
as we have we have
proposed them in the new pact
on migration and asylum so the question
is not at all whether  the
finance commission of border management measures
the question is
such that what has been asked is to
know whether the Finance and
Walls or Barbed Wire and Borders Committee
and on that we recalled that we
have never done it and that there is
no intention of doing it on this
subject I can also  recalled the
historical importance of the fact that the
european union was built on in a
situation of walls and fences
existed in europe and that what
were your that
they have since been abolished and that the
mission of the  of the european union
is to build a europe
which develops fundamental rights
freedom
democracy equality the rule of law and that it is
also in this context that the
commission has never financed two
walls or fence barbed wire and do
not intend to do so in the future
oliva on this subject
if so
then I am a former Jesuit student
so I appreciate the great
sophistry which is so dear to the
European commission but I now give you
the  example of the border  he
bulgarian turkish that i visited
three years ago there is a fence to pay
in the
bouillard government which is very efficient there is
almost no
illegal immigration after towards
turkey
this border is behind the fence
there are seven systems  integrated financed by
the european union it was
48.4
million to
[Music]
40.4 million euros in the european budget
discerno security against bulgaria
whose former during the former
financial period and the bulgarians say that
works very well because if we manage
to skip
that one, the fence is the
management that does it with the cameras
with the helicopters etc. which is
activated so isn't it a bit
hypocritical to say that we are financing  not the
fences if at the same time we finance a
system
whereby they walk hand in hand
with the fences and breaking the
fence is a much more
economical way of using public funds
than cameras, helicopters and
so on  et cetera
since in the end it is two in
fact to defend the
external borders of the european union and it
has nothing to do with with the
soviet union with the 60s 50s when
was created
in the  albert thank you good i don't
know how productive for us
to get into a debate
about how best to manage this
or that part
of the union's external border i think it's
something  something that has to be assessed
every year by experts
both from the member states of our
frontex agency and possibly from the
commission, and we have processes
to do this with what we call
frontex in English and with the
horse
mechanism a schengen evaluation mechanism who
also works with
who organizes the work of the experts to
keep this in detail on your
question of
6.6 it would be better to devote our
funds to such and such and such and such measure
what I can  maybe reminder  It
is simply that the objective
of integrated border management that
you rightly recalled is not
to have a border that is watertight
but a border that is well managed,
that is to say that it  is a border
where no one can cross
without being undetected or
attempts to cross the border
illegally without are
prevented by the
infrastructure we have but where at the same
time access to the asylum procedure  in
particular is insured and it is also
a border where
illegal smuggling activities cannot take place
so exactly how this
can be accomplished maybe at this or that
part of the border it will depend
on
the circumstances at that place
thank you  I don't see any more questions
on this subject and therefore I pass the floor
to look h
and apart
from police 40 years in all
versions to cause in many
balls symbol of all mats
for on our unif  elm worse to play
think we are in territories
and connections of good
loads of snowboarding business
after good
ideas context continues
to
stagnate these young
girls or
crisis nicolas
and peter hello i had a question
about bosnia herzegovina i  wanted to
have two details of a laziness I
think it's a debate at the
united nations security council
are you worried about the turn of the
debates
with a russia which seems to be taking
hostage a little bit the operation will do there
letea and its renewal for
various reasons secondly i wanted to
know what your reaction was
we were surprised this weekend a
bulgarian soldier and died by
firearm in sarajevo in operation ufo
rattle t 1 friday the same day of
life  ' of the military committee this
information was made public
by the Bulgarian authorities and we
were very surprised at the response of
the spokesperson of the mission or that she
we  asked for information
as usual in a classic way to
confirm information and get
details it's our job
and this spokesperson seems to have
gone wrong because he started to
criticize our work to say that we
act in a way  unprofessional
because we had dared to make a small
comment on a photo saying that
the mission preferred to put photos
of medal presentations than anything else and
ten years that we were not professional
that we are trying to put some  oil on the
fire and who did not answer us this
information
is this behavior of a
press officer dependent on the authority of the
high representative in cooperation
with the weather and an order given not
to communicate and set fires  the
journalists because his e-mail I
send it to you is incendiary
it is not worthy of an officer in a
European Union operation this
officer so we clearly ask
for a very clear clarification of the m  Does
this officer know if he received an
order to do so? Is it an
order from his force commander who I
remember an Austrian general
fps militants where does he know what
was agreed?  with the authorities
of nato and with the tories the
european union and what measure you
envisage as a disciplinary measure
against such behavior I must say that it
is totally shameful
I have been doing the press for 20 years it has been
several years  not to say
that I have been working on
the psdc program for a good ten years I have never received an
email of this tone there also defamatory
good on the first part of your
question on bosnia the situation in
bosnia in general it  is a source of
great concern for the union a point you
have noted a lot of
political activities last week
especially on the grounds in bosnia
with the visit of ours to a direct
will have foreign action service
with the american partner po  ur
to try to find the solution of
the crisis kiki and allure bosnia in the
present and the mission althea i have a
very important part for the stability
security in the country we follow we have
of course the discussions which are
planned for today could  one
day soon in the
security council of the united nations but it is
not for us comments and to this
discussion of which we await the
discussion we hope we
expect that the mandate of six years
extended of this very
important mission for bosnia and we  we are
very very con me for the mission and
it was also a comfort but by the
conclusions of the foreign affairs council of
the last
foreign affairs council of 18 years from
October I think
on the second part of the question
it is not for me  commented on your
bilateral exchange with the
press office partner of a
European union mission without
knowing all the details so I
cannot comment  lie about the about the
details you suddenly
mentioned mans
there are there other foreign affairs issues
for us slips
if a stage a rate
of integration is continuous all that we have
two players
at the partisan opportunities passing from 600
think
thank you
for peter
question
yes infects peter i am going to come back
to bosnia i would like to come back to the
report by representative christian
schmidt who is very very worried i
would like to know if you share his
concern about a risk of secession and
if i have listened  what you said is a
source of great concern and
do you have these elements where he
talks about the threats posed by the
Serbian separatists with their desire to
recreate a new army and
what can you
foresee  as a measure at this
level thank
you thank you christian combes Thursday the
situation now in bosnia and
herzegovina 7 years a source of great
concern in the european union but also
of a lot of action  diplomatic services
as I have already said there was a
high-level visit a
joint European and American
visit to Bosnia for monsters and it is an
attachment of the European Union and the
United States to find solutions for
the crisis
our  representative in bosnia we were able to meet
with the political leaders
in bosnia and herzegovina to deliver all
the messages is the message of the
european union it is very clear to the
divisive rhetoric
unilateral actions
that would take one day must be stopped  for the terrible
in terris territorial sovereignty and
the dignity of bosnia must be
stopped we must engage in political dialogue
because the insolent
constructive scheme the solution forward forward
for a found the solution to this
crisis is the dialogue between the
political leaders and when i say
unilateral actions to it the
divisive rhetoric must be stopped
for the benefit of the people of
bosnia and for  r the benefit
of bosnia
and herzegovina's european perspective and our engagement with
bosnia artigues ovine continues to
continue it was not just the
visit last week but we
continue with our commitment and
activity to attend the
political leaders in bosnia
herzegovina found the solution to this crisis
thank you i no longer see that a raised hand
mirage was actually hiding a case
and 5 8 years old nicholas rapid eye want to
know where we and
technical [Music] adviser
to the management
who has neither  wade rolled red nicaragua
mr gametes every thing possible
authorizes victory removing reason is
opened
internet users and massages actions
sodifrance
because of
democratic fire our father and our international rhino
tony dinozzo evident in
nicaragua
nicaragua great balls of action on
the content of your
[Music]
negative situation
saint gobain
democratic
fundamental m6 action is coming would
benefit  of a
regime for nicaragua few people have
been poutine sanctions to the regime
between 10 roger meece constant customers of
solid review we listen will have to make
vestiges and the mythical nass wind and this
context
if we end rich in fauna facing
the 5th and 8th  of the two regions frost of the
worlds phil
ivey
goods would have been shot of
law in the european commission ah yeah
abbott ten attacks which took place in
games and diabetics or offices in
den boogaerde capital on a
european attack and cameron a world is accident
and
visit in  china of 15
da site of 13 anyway first
look if my son christiane
2010 and non-specific training
moments of sunshine each college a welcome
back to you balladur you
and you tube
[Music]
vim
[ __ ] you
and you de  what with us hand
de sefyu
christian
you seem to have a
connection problem yes here I had disconnected
because I had remained open
just now  a small question on
Friday their france is going to meet
sefcovic I remain to be seen if sir I
think will also meet sir
singh habitus who takes care of
the fishing file I know that these two files are
totally different finally they
are both very withdrawn from the kingdom  united
and therefore we are in
fairly sensitive discussions I think that Mr.
frost will meet the French leaders on
Thursday is there a union
that is planned for Friday at the
listening point we cannot answer this
question
so indeed the meeting
with our leaders  policies is confirmed
for the rest tim has already answered
questions in regards
to ongoing fishing discussions
are there any other questions for us
today
luca
schena from game
october ferti
gaspare from gaza the topic manulife is a
hold  up paris aids and parks line
with its consequences
lately its sense west tourists
of a
program schedule this
obse  rvation
because if a common project
or from
Canada next
communication
we say we will mark
our 100 km / h in 6 months